[Musique]
vous avez été nombreux à nous demander
pourquoi vous faites plus de vidéos ça
nous manque alors c'est vrai que
j'essaye de limiter les propos de
jean-marc parce que certaines personnes
ne trouvent un peu limite parfois ça
s'appelle comment sa façade et ol j'ai
dit
c'est quoi ça ah ça c'est parce qu'on
m'a dit que tu étais trop vulgaire alors
du coup j'ai mis un petit boîtier qui
sont sur des gros mots là par exemple
n'a pas le droit de dire non mais j'ai
dit ça des toits human ans j'ai pas dit
ça
mais à sa série 10 mais je te dis quand
je dirige a bat pour faire gaffe c'est
dur d'un chien tu habites alors j'ai
tenu j'ai dit 'on kaaba et les 506
répertoire c'est quoi cette vie de
football j'ai toujours dit
wei coucou makes
the titans qui va passer toute sa vie
ouais faut pas que tu foutent le bordel
dans la maison comme un retour à ce que
c'est vrai et on se tait à bientôt et
vision
[Musique]
dd il est un spécimen très rare qui se
déplacent souvent très longtemps
elle a pour habitude de parler tout seul
malgré sa petite taille elle est
toujours aux aguets et reste très féroce
elle ne sent jamais rien elle peut
rester sur son canapé pendant des heures
à regarder dans le vide là c'est pour
élever l'état elle peut mettre plusieurs
années pour apprendre le fonctionnement
d'une simple télécommande au mahdi ces
nouveaux sons l'approché il faut être
très courageux et lui parler dans son
langage ses manies abois bah ouais
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
tikhonov katie holmes